OK, let's let's unpack this.
Imagine a place where ancient
evils don't just look, they kind
of thrive, right?
Where the mists themselves, they
hide these unimaginable horrors.
And you know, even your closest
allies, maybe they have their
own chilling agendas or secrets.
Definitely.
That's the kind of world we're
stepping into today.
It's a realm where dread isn't
just like a mood.
No, it's constant, woven right
into the fabric of the place.
Yeah, a companion.
Almost.
Exactly.
So we're diving deep into
session 18 of a Dungeons and
Dragons campaign.
This one's run masterfully by
Dungeon Master Sean S, and we're
really focusing on the players
here.
Sean D is your horn Tenpenny?
OK, Chris laying Radley and Trip
is Dermont Cobain.
Gotcha.
And look, this isn't just any
game session, right?
It's a really high stakes
narrative.
It's just brimming with these
desperate choices, brutal
realities.
Yeah.
And that persistent, almost soul
crushing weight you get in a
truly cursed land like Barovia.
OK, so our mission for this deep
dive then is to pull out the
most important bits of
knowledge, the key insights from
this this really grouping story,
right?
We'll explore this daring rescue
attempt they mount in Borovia
will dissect the the fragile
alliances they forge under
pressure.
Forged in fire practice.
Exactly.
And confront the brutal reality
of a world where justice is
well, it's swift, it's public,
and often it's fatal.
Absolutely final.
So get ready for some surprising
facts, maybe some Keem analysis,
and a story that honestly, it
keeps you hooked.
It should offer some deep
insights into, you know,
storytelling and player choices
in a horror setting.
So we kick things off in the
desolate, Miss Shrouded land of
Borovia.
Yeah, classic.
Yeah, and this isn't just, you
know, any old fantasy realm you
stumble into.
Yeah, not at all.
It's the quintessential horror
setting.
Dread isn't just lurking in the
shadows.
It's everywhere.
It's in the wind.
It's in the quiet moments.
It feels meticulously designed
to make you, the listener, feel
just perpetually uneasy.
Constantly on edge, and what's
really fascinating here, and
honestly it's critical to
understanding Borovia, is this
concept of it being a domain of
dread.
OK, what does that mean exactly?
Well, these aren't just places
on a map.
They're like pockets of reality,
twisted realities ruled entirely
by these powerful, malevolent
beings.
Dark Lords.
Dark Lords, right?
And once you're trapped inside
their borders, escape is so the
detail that Dermont Cobain, one
of our main guys here, he found
himself here accidentally.
He's described as an unwitting
prisoner of the Mists.
Unwitting prisoner.
That sets a tone.
Immediately, it establishes this
pervasive sense of doom hanging
over everything, and it
highlights 1 of Borovia score
functions.
Narratively, speakers, it's a
prison.
It's walls are invisible, but
they're inescapable.
For a Dungeon Master.
That concept, it's brilliant for
keeping the stakes incredibly
high.
Every character knows the exit
isn't just through some gate.
Yeah, you can't just walk out.
And right at the heart of all
this darkness, driving the main
conflict for the session we're
looking at, yeah, are Derman's
friends Traxidor and Radley.
They're not just lost.
No, it's worse.
They are held captive by the
Burga mistress of Awlaki, Lady
Watcher.
Lady Watcher, a significant
figure.
Seems like it.
She clearly wields this absolute
kind of unquestioned power in
her part of Barovia.
Cold and unyielding, like the
mists themselves.
That's a good way to put it.
Hashtag tag, tag #introducing
our protagonists and their
pasts.
So let's talk about these
individuals thrown into this
this nightmare, starting with
Dermot Cobain.
He's an elf, an Arcane
Trickster, and this is not his
first taste of Borovia, not by a
long shot.
He's already seen horrors more
than most could probably handle.
Right, he's got some history
there.
His recent past alone sounds
like a harrowing adventure
novel.
He talks about battling
monstrous druids on Yesterhill.
Master your business.
Destroying this enormous blight
called Winter Splinter.
Oh yeah, I remember that.
Encountering a truly deranged
celestial being pretending to be
an Abbot.
That sounds unsettling.
And even retrieving a wedding
dress for this Abbot at his like
bizarre requests.
OK, a wedding dress in Borovia.
Right.
So this guy has absolutely been
through the ringer.
It's kind of amazing he's still
functional.
And that recap?
It's not just a laundry list of
D&D encounters, you know, No.
It tells you something.
It really highlights Dierman's
incredible resilience, his
resourcefulness, especially
under Borovia's constant
escalating threats.
He's not new to Danger, then.
Not at all.
But his experiences, they
vividly under score the sheer
variety, the brutality of
challenges you face in this
land.
He's already pushed the
boundaries of survival.
Probably sanity too.
Yeah.
Probably.
Which makes his current
predicament, his friends
captured facing execution, even
more compelling.
It adds real weight to his
motivation.
So he's not just some Nubian
over his.
Head Exactly.
He's a seasoned survivor, even
if accidentally seasoned, and
now he's facing this intensely
personal crisis.
That kind of back story, even if
it's recent, gives a character
depth.
It justifies their desperation.
Which you need in a horror game.
Crucial for emotional
investment?
Definitely.
Then we've got your horn,
Tenpenny Halfling Beastmaster.
OK, different archetype.
Totally different.
In stark contrast to Derrimon,
Yuri Horn is a Mist Walker.
He purposefully came to Borovia.
OK, that's a big difference.
Walked right into it.
Yeah.
His motivation clear, singular,
like a laser focus revenge.
Revenge against who?
Against Straud himself, the Dark
Lord of the whole domain.
Wow, OK, aiming high.
Right, he walked into the
nightmare instead of being
dragged and kicking and
screaming.
So if we connect that to the
bigger picture, the contrast
between dear Amman, the
accidental victim, and Eurohorn,
the driven hunter seeking this
deeply personal vengeance, it's
striking.
Really striking.
It creates an interesting
dynamic right away.
It does this immediate shared
goal, rescuing Darwin's friends.
It forms a powerful alliance,
but maybe a temporary one Could
be.
And it raises an important
question for us and for any
player in that spot.
What does it really mean to rely
on someone whose ultimate goal
is this personal vendetta
against the big bad of the land?
Does it make him more reliable
or more dangerous?
Exactly.
Is he more reliable because his
motivation is so clear, or is he
actually more dangerous to
associate with because his
ultimate goal might just over
shadow the party's immediate
needs?
That's fertile ground for some
interesting party conflict.
Or moral dilemmas.
Yeah, fascinating potential
there.
So facing this dire situation,
clocks ticking, Eurohorn's first
move is to go see his one
resource in Barovia.
OK, who's that?
The legendary Monster Hunter
Rudolph Van Richten.
He finds him at the Blue Water
Inn.
Van Richten A classic but often
hard to pin down.
Totally.
And he even notes Van Richten's
current disguise.
He's magically disguised as a
circus entertainer.
A.
Circus entertainer?
Seriously.
OK, that adds a layer of
weirdness.
Intrigue.
Maybe it's that classic DND
thing, the wise old sage, but
Borovia tends to twist
expectations, doesn't it?
It really does.
And what's insightful here is
Ven Richton's nature.
He's highly guarded, the
description says.
He opens the door slightly,
just, yeah, the small detail.
But it speaks volumes, right?
About his caution, his life of
secrecy, maybe even paranoia as
a Monster Hunter.
He's seen things.
Definitely.
He's legendary, known for his
skill, his knowledge, but even a
master like him has limitations.
Clear ones.
Like what?
His focus is entirely on his
deeply personal mission, revenge
against his nemesis Strad.
Right.
The same target as your horn,
ultimately.
Yes, but it makes him
surprisingly indifferent to what
he just dismisses as local
politics or the inner workings
of Falaki's civics.
So he doesn't care about the
prisoners?
Not really his department,
apparently.
In this interaction, it's a
powerful lesson for Dungeon
Masters I.
Think how so?
Even powerful, famous MPCS.
They aren't universal problem
solvers.
They have their own agendas,
their own limits, their own
blind spots.
Right, they're not just vending
machines for help.
Exactly.
And that dramatically raises the
stakes for the players.
It removes what might have
seemed like an obvious path to a
solution.
Yeah, and the disappointment for
Eurohorn.
He can almost feel it.
He clearly hoped Van Richten
could help.
But despite all that hope, Van
Richten simply does not know
where prisoners would be kept in
Volaki.
Full stop.
Dead end.
Basically, yeah, a dead end for
this specific, very urgent
problem that's tough to swallow
when lives are on the line.
It forces them to pivot
immediately, yeah, to ditch
their ideas about how things
should work.
So while your horn's hitting
that wall, yeah, Duron being
resourceful, he questions.
Danica, the innkeeper at the
Blue Water Inn, takes a more,
you know, grassroots approach.
Smart move, talk to the locals.
And her news is chilling.
It confirms their worst fears.
There's no prison in Valaki.
Not in the traditional sense.
No prison.
What do they do then?
She explains that serious crimes
in Valaki, they're met with one
of two brutal outcomes.
OK, execution or the convicted
or banished from town?
Banished.
Is that better?
She says it's often just a
slower form of execution.
Oh, right into the mists,
presumably.
Exactly.
It paints this vivid picture of
a, well, a totalitarian regime.
That detail, it just starkly
highlights Falaki's justice
system.
Brutal.
Incredibly efficient.
Not about rehabilitation.
Clearly, no.
It's about swift public
deterrence, elimination, pure
authoritarian control.
Public displays of power.
And Danica predicts something
else, too.
She thinks Lady Water will want
to stage a public spectacle, A
mock trial, before the
execution.
A.
Sure, trial.
Yeah, with an announcement
coming in the morning, this
immediately sets that ticking
clock.
Right time is running out fast.
It reveals the ruthless power
structure in Valaki control
through fear, through these
public displays of absolute
authority.
It's calculated.
Punish the individuals, terrify
the populace, Remind everyone
who's boss.
So if we step back, what does
this all mean for Dermont and
you're a horn?
Well, they've got no traditional
rescue options, yeah.
No sneaking into a dungeon cell.
Nope.
They're up against a powerful,
ruthless authority figure in
Lady Watcher.
Who has guards, presumably.
Definitely, and they've got mere
hours until a public execution
designed is this theatrical
display of power.
So subtle options are out.
Politics.
Negotiations.
Forget it.
Gone.
This confluence of factors just
eliminates all that.
The stage is truly set for a
desperate gamble.
No time for finesse.
No room for clever tricks.
Only bold direct action remains.
Classic DM move right?
Ratchet up the pressure.
Force the players into a corner.
Makes their choices intense,
personal, high stakes?
Absolutely.
So with this dire news hanging
over them, the clock ticking
relentlessly, your horn takes
matters into his own hands.
OK, what does he do?
After Dermont goes to bed, your
horn defies the town.
Strict curfew.
Risky, very risky under watchers
rule.
Yeah, but it's not for an
immediate rescue attempt.
Not yet.
It's for something more
personal, but, you know,
ultimately crucial, which is to
retrieve his Panther companion.
The beast master needs his
beast.
Makes sense?
But the ACT itself, just going
out after curfew, is a huge
personal risk solely for his
animal.
That says something about his
character, doesn't it?
Absolutely that choice.
It speaks volumes about Yuri
Horn, about his bond with his
companion in the survival game
like Borovia, where every single
resource is precious,
prioritizing an animal companion
over your own safety, or even
over the immediate rescue that
reveals his core value.
We'll take companionship.
Exactly, and define curfew under
watchers new strict rule.
Incredibly dangerous, especially
when the text paints this
picture of almost all residents
staying in their homes.
The town's terrified.
Palpable fear, which makes your
horns stealthy movements even
more impressive and risky.
For a beast master, the beast
isn't just a pet, right?
At all.
It's a partner, an extension of
himself in combat, for tracking,
for utility.
Your horn is clearly willing to
go to great lengths for it,
risking his own life.
Shows how much companionship
matters in a place like Barovia.
Especially in a lonely,
dangerous world like that.
It's a powerful narrative beat
character over pure tactics in
that moment.
So he demonstrates these
impressive Ranger skills moving
through the dark, fear ridden
town.
Slipping through shadows.
Quickly slips through the
decrepit dwellings.
Easily avoids being seen.
Real stealth master stuff.
He waits patiently, exercising
extreme caution, perfect timing,
until the single washman passes
along the palisade.
Then he makes his move, climbs
the wall.
OK showcases his tactical
thinking, his agility, and the
mention of Shalal de Fries.
Oh yeah, those sharpened stakes
at the bottom.
Exactly those long, sharpened
stakes designed to impale
attackers that adds this vivid,
dangerous detail to Valaki's
defenses.
Makes the climb even more
precarious.
And highlights his skill, right?
It's not just climbing, it's
navigating a death trap for Adm
Those environmental details?
Fantastic for making even simple
movement feel tense.
Turns a skill check into a real
narrative moment.
Precisely.
So once he's safely up on the
battlement, your horn lets out a
piercing whistle.
Calling his companion.
Yeah.
After a tense minute, a dark
silhouette of a Panther
cautiously emerges from the tree
line.
OK, here it comes.
Then it just springs from cover,
dashes to the palisade, leaps
over the Cheval to freeze.
Wow, Agile cat.
And easily scales over, using
its claws to grip the barrier.
It's an incredible visual,
almost cinematic.
A great reunion moment, but then
comes the twist.
Right.
Oh yeah, The twist.
The reunion, powerful as it is,
gets immediately darkened by
this gruesome discovery.
What is it?
The Panther has a well hey
putrefying A severed human
forearm in its jaws.
Oh lovely.
Welcome to Borovia.
Right.
The source material even
speculates it could be the
partial remains of an
unfortunate resident, maybe
someone dragged off during that
vampire spawn attack on the
town.
That just injects this chilling
detail, a visceral reminder of
Borovia's constant casual
brutality.
And the Panthers nature too.
And the raw, primal nature of
Eurohorn's companion.
Yeah, even in a moment of
relief, Borovia slaps you with
its horror.
The dread never really lifts.
It's brilliant environmental
storytelling and character
reinforcement.
The beast is wild, this world is
monstrous, and the interaction
between your horn and the
Panther is great too.
Your horn has to coax it from
the great cat.
Doesn't want to give up its
pride.
No, the cat growls menacingly as
he extracts the arm from its
mouth.
Then he just tosses the grizzly
thing over the wall.
Gets rid of the evidence.
And the cat resentfully regards
the halfling Ranger.
Resentfully.
That's perfect.
This short exchange, it shows
the bond but also the animal's
untamed nature.
It's not just a loyal puppy.
It's a perfect encapsulation of
their relationship.
Deep trust, loyalty, sure, but
also respect for the animal's
wildness, even its disturbing
acquisitions.
That relationship itself becomes
a narrative tool for the DM.
Capable of generating
heartwarming moments and deeply
unsettling ones like this.
So with his companion now
begrudgingly with him, your horn
clutches the Panther by the
loose skin at the nape of its
neck and leaps onto its back.
Right in the Panther.
Nice.
The cat quietly pads through the
town's alleys as your horn
guides it back toward the Blue
Water Inn, trying to stay
hidden.
Stealth mode engaged again.
But the urgency ramps up again.
They hear a guard patrol coming
down the street just as they're
near the inn.
Close call forces your horn to
quickly shove the Panther into
hiding beneath an earthen crawl
space.
Got to hide the evidence and the
giant cat.
Then he slips back inside
himself, narrowly avoiding
detection.
This whole sequence just
portrays that tension, that
constant threat of living under
an oppressive regime.
Every shadow's a threat.
Every sound could be discovery.
It's a master class and building
suspense through detail.
A truly tense but ultimately
successful solo mission.
He got his companion back.
Gathered A crucial asset for the
next day's desperate plan.
Definitely going to need every
advantage.
Yeah.
And Yuri Horn just proved he'll
take extreme risks for what he
thinks is necessary.
Reinforces that self reliant
driven nature.
Which is admirable, but may be
dangerous in a party dynamic
sometimes.
We'll see.
Day 14 Dawns casts this grim,
heavy light over Valaki, a real
stark contrast to the stealthy
shadows of the night before.
The mood shifts with the light.
Your horn and dermont, they
don't waste any time.
Immediately leave the inn on
this mission of recognizance.
Scouting you got to see the
layout.
Meticulously scouting alleys,
roads, everything leading
towards the village square.
They know what's coming.
They need to see the playing
field, assess the threat, look
for any potential advantages.
Smart preparation is key,
especially when you're
outnumbered.
And the shift from night secrecy
to the starkness of day brings
this different kind of tension,
doesn't it?
Yeah, it does.
The Borovian overcast lightens,
the text says, sets this somber,
almost foreboding tone for the
day's events.
They've gathered Intel.
Now they need to prepare
physically, mentally, for the
grim reality waiting for them.
That transition highlights the
relentless nature of the threat.
There's no real respite, just a
change in the form of the
pressure.
The DM is using time effectively
here, accelerating the timeline,
forcing immediate action.
Definitely no time to overthink.
And Danica's prediction from the
night before, chillingly
accurate, solidifies Lady
Watchers authority.
Criers can be heard from corner
to corner, their voices echoing
through the somber morning air
announcing the trial.
Show trial.
With the Outsiders to be held at
high noon.
It wasn't just a rumor, it was a
promise she made good on.
That public proclamation ensures
the whole town knows.
Yeah, makes it inescapable.
Yeah, and the charges against
Tracidor and Radley are specific
severe.
Let's hear them.
Attacking the Reeves,
challenging the burger
mistress's authority and killing
several members of her guard.
OK, serious stuff in her eyes.
For these crimes, they'll be
tried for mayhem, murder and
disturbing the peace of Valaki.
Wow, quite the list.
This public denouncement, it's a
powerful tool, right?
Legitimizes the execution in the
public eye.
Cements Watchers authority.
Calculated move, punish, and
instill fear Create a public
deterrent against any dissent.
This isn't just justice, it's a
performance of power.
Absolutely.
So when your horn and dearman
arrive at the square, they're
confronted with this stark,
undeniable symbol.
The gallows.
Workers are just finishing the
construction of a gallows right
there in the town square.
Oh man, that's grim.
It's a physical manifestation of
the deadline, a grim counter to
any hope they might have had
left.
That detail just creates this
overwhelming sense of dread
seeing it being built.
Confirms Danica's prophecy, but
also shows the efficiency of the
ruthlessness of Watchers regime.
It's more than just an execution
site.
It's a public display meant to
instill fear, obedience.
Transforms the town square into
a theater of state sanctioned
violence.
For the players, seeing that
structure, yeah, must be an
enormous weight, emphasizes the
finality, the slim window they
have left to act.
It's effective visual shorthand
for Doom is coming.
Totally.
So facing this grim scene,
knowing time is incredibly
short, they quickly hatch a
plan.
Got to think fast.
Plan is to strike from
concealment.
You're a horn.
Using his Ranger skills, his
Panther, he'll get up on the
rooftops.
High.
Great advantage, good thinking.
Leverage that position.
Meanwhile, Derriman will hide
amid the rubble of a burnt out
foundation.
Using cover, maximizing surprise
that tactical choice shows their
adaptability resourcefulness
under extreme pressure.
Classic guerrilla tactics,
right?
Mitigate the guards numbers,
launch a surprise assault and
that burnt out foundation
detail.
Poignant how so suggests a place
may be raised by previous
conflicts, A grim reminder of
Valaki's volatile history now
serving as this temporary, grim
hiding spot.
Symbolizes the cycle of
destruction and defiance.
Exactly.
This plan is desperate though.
Yeah, Relies entirely on
surprise.
Perfect coordination.
As noon gets closer and closer,
your home goes down to get his
Panther.
And we get the heavy hitter.
And here's the subtle, almost
darkly funny detail hints at the
Panthers personality, maybe the
mundane next to the horror.
God is it.
He grimaces when he sees loose
chicken feathers scattered along
the opening of the cat's hiding
place.
Then he notices the absence of
the Martikoff's chickens that
are usually scratching behind
the.
End the Panther got snacky.
Apparently, what stands out here
is this brilliant subtle touch
of dark humor character detail.
After having its special arm
prize.
Right, the Panther sought its
own revenge on the innkeepers
chickens.
Reinforces the animals primal
nature.
Hunters instincts went out as
this moment of unexpected
levity, or maybe just a reminder
of the wildness always present
in Barovia.
Even in the tamed beasts, amidst
these grim preparations for a
deadly fight.
It's a small beat but it grounds
the fantastic, adds personality.
I love it.
And Eurohorn's reaction quickly
mounts.
His cat departs before anyone
begins asking questions.
Smart.
No time to explain missing
poultry.
Shows his quick thinking, clear
priorities even in this weird
moment.
Pragmatic, very in character.
Absolutely got to focus on the
mission.
So the clock ticks closer to
noon.
The town square slowly starts to
fill up.
Two Time 4 town guards attend a
growing crowd of dreary
Barovians.
But the crowd, They're described
as sullen and morose.
Not exactly a festive
atmosphere.
No, mostly standing still and
silently staring ahead.
No joyous anticipation.
No mob bang for blood.
It's chillingly subdued.
That depiction of the crowd is
incredibly telling, isn't it?
Yeah, what does it say they're.
Not excited?
They're resigned, maybe even
desensitized, to these public
displays of brutality.
Broken maybe?
It underscores the pervasive
despair, the iron grip of
authority in Valaki.
Their silence is almost more
chilling, speaks more volumes
about the town state than any
uproar could.
Suggests the populace so crushed
by fear, they've lost the will
to react.
Serves as this powerful backdrop
for the adventurers desperate
actions maximizes their sense of
isolation.
OK, so as planned, the hidden
strike force takes position
Eurohorn's riding his Panther
companion to a position on the
rooftops overlooking the town
square.
Ready for the aerial assault?
Across the square, Dermont is
concealed amid the rubble of a
house that was raised during the
massacre of the Festival of the
Blazing Sun.
Oof, that reference again.
The massacre of the festival,
The blazing sun.
Adds another layer of grim
history to Valaki.
Strongly suggests previous
uprisings.
Brutal crack downs hints at the
town's volatile past, its
present, a place where peace is
fragile, rebellion is crushed.
Dermont hiding in the ruins of
that event.
Grimly poetic.
A constant silent reminder of
the consequences of defiance,
even as he prepares.
His own act of defiance
reinforces that cycle of
oppression and rebellion.
And then the prisoners arrive.
Oh boy, here we go.
Tracidor and Radley are driven
into the town square in a cart,
both bound by manacles that
restrain their hands and legs,
utterly helpless.
No chance to resist or defend
themselves.
And the conditions are cruel.
Tracidor seems sedated.
Drugged, robbed at his agency.
Awful.
While Radley his head is clapped
in an eyeless iron mask.
An eyeless mask.
Brutal.
Blinding him, humiliating him.
Vulnerable.
They're prodded by guards up the
gallows as the townsfolk just
watch emotionlessly.
It's a calculated display of
power, dehumanization, stripping
them of dignity, serving as a
chilling warning designed to
make the players furious.
And Lady Watcher in the Reeve
ride in on horseback flanked by
two wardens.
The big entrance.
Lady Washer dismounts, walks to
the head of the gallows
platform, addresses the crowd,
making a big show, setting the
narrative her.
Speech must be something.
It's a master class and
political rhetoric, fear
mongering designed to solidify
her power, justify the
execution.
What did she say?
She proclaims people of Valaki
twice.
The piece I have striven these
past days to create has been
violated, violated by these very
brigands.
Claiming them for everything.
These lawless men have not
justified my authority, but even
the Craven Vargas Valakovic had
these very men banished.
And yet they returned to murder
and sow chaos.
But no more.
For today, their crime shall be
exposed, and Valaki will have
justice.
Painting herself is the savior
of peace, justifying the
harshness, leveraging past
fears, present control.
Classic villain speech.
For Adm, prime example of using
NPC dialogue, build character
reinforced themes, escalate
tension right before the fight.
Absolutely.
So the Reeve steps forward,
poised to brandish the charges.
The formal part, but.
Before he can say a word, he's
pierced by Derman and your
horn's arrows.
Bam, ambush launched.
Where Desperate Gambit begins.
This is it.
The moment they chose your
horns.
Arrows are especially nasty,
exploding in a cloud of thorns.
Ouch.
Peppers.
The burger mistress in a nearby
guard immediately creates chaos,
hinders the main target.
And the reefs?
Instant death.
His corpse topples onto gallows
before he realizes he had been
slain.
Swift.
Brutal, and a wave of cold Glee
of revenge washes over Derman.
Understandable, but Walter
reacts instantly.
Really.
Immediately cast Sanctuary.
Protects herself from direct
attacks.
Smart move.
Defensive magic.
Her wardens, the elite magical
guards.
Identify the assassins.
Instantly cast spiritual weapon.
Start shooting necromantic
bolts.
OK, the counter attack begins.
Battle is joined.
Immediate deadly chaos erupts.
The narrative planning gives way
to pure tactical combat and then
a true moment of surprise, a
revelation that doesn't just
turn the tide, it completely
redefines things.
What happens?
It sounds big.
Moments later, Irwin and Danica
flutter to the galas in the form
of Ravens, then morph into
humanoid.
Were Ravens.
Whoa.
The Martikoffs.
The innkeepers.
The very same they immediately
engage the guards trying to free
the prisoners.
Were Ravens.
OK, that is fascinating.
The seemingly ordinary, helpful
innkeepers reveal their true
nature.
Members of the Keeples of the
Feather.
A powerful, totally unexpected
alliance for the players, for us
listening.
Nobody saw that coming right
then.
They risk everything by openly
intervening.
Transforms the situation from a
two man ambush into this
broader, more chaotic melee with
powerful hidden allies.
Makes you wonder, how long were
they waiting for a chance like
this to act against Wachter?
Exactly what does this reveal
about their true motives, Their
long term commitment to fighting
the darkness in Borovia?
It instantly complicates the
power dynamics in Valaki offers
the players these powerful,
maybe risky, new allies.
Classic D&D twist.
Even in the darkest places,
secret forces work against evil.
Amazing moment.
So with chaos unleashed, the
fight becomes this brutal
struggle.
Even blinded by that iron mask,
Radley reacts instantly.
What?
Can he even do?
Head butts the guards
accompanying him, breaks the
guards nose.
His mask rings like a cooking
pan being struck.
Oh, OK, Sheer ferocity.
The crowd finally breaks their
silence, scatters in terror
witnessing the raw violence.
Highlights Radley's martial
prowess.
Even restrained and blinded,
he's formidable, swinging his
head like a club, testament to
his raw power, his fighting
spirit.
Severely hindered but still
dangerous.
Shows his will to fight is just
unyielding.
For a player, that kind of
immediate, visceral reaction,
despite the penalties, credibly
satisfying to role play,
showcases the character score.
Meanwhile, the War Ravens, the
Martakovs, they're hard pressed
by guards.
Bolstered by Watchers presents,
probably.
Yeah, they're getting stabbed
repeatedly by spear, but
valiantly continue to press
their attack, showing immense
courage, surprising resilience.
Emphasizes their unwavering
commitment to the rescue despite
the odds.
The in danger they're taking
significant damage shows how
dangerous watchers forces are
head on.
Especially with her boosting
them.
Their resilience is remarkable,
reveals them as powerful, self
sacrificing allies willing to
pay a heavy price.
This isn't casual.
It's a desperate, costly gamble
for them too.
And your Horn and Derman, they
try to seize this chance, right?
Target Lady Walker herself.
Try to end it quickly.
Makes sense.
Cut off the head.
But they're thwarted.
Her sanctuary spell it in
sources, their minds.
They literally cannot make
themselves attacker.
Forced to engage other targets,
it's going to be frustrating.
How incredibly frustrating is
that for a player unable to
strike the primary target, the
source of the conflict, because
of magic?
Sanctuary is a powerful defense.
Protects the caster, forces the
attackers to deal with her
bodyguards first.
Prevents that quick, decisive
resolution.
Brilliant DM choice extends the
challenge, shows how formidable
the opposition really is.
Definitely.
So you're a horn up on the
rooftops on his Panther.
He outpaces the Warden's
spiritual weapon manifestations,
keeps firing arrows into the
chaos below, trying to control
the battlefield.
But the Wardens are relentless.
Right, totally besieging your
horn with necrotic bolt spells,
and Dearman in his rubble hiding
spot gets forced back as another
cast inflict wounds on him.
Ouch, heavy damage.
The fight is far from 1 sided.
Shows the brutal ebb and flow,
the constant pressure.
The Wardens are powerful magic
users, applying pressure
debilitating spells from
multiple angles.
And watchers, not just standing
there.
No, she directly intervenes,
heals a wounded Warden,
reinvigorating him to resume the
fight.
Active role, powerful support,
extends the fight, stops her
forces from being overwhelmed
easily.
It's a well coordinated magical
defense they're up against.
Pushing them to their absolute
limits.
So despite the initial surprise
advantage and the Ravens jumping
in a.
Huge help.
The adventurers are still
fundamentally hindered.
Tracidor is drugged, useless,
Radley is restrained, blind, and
the sheer relentlessness of
their onslaught wears down the
party.
Fighting uphill against
overwhelming odds.
Illustrates the critical impact
of being disadvantaged, fighting
superior numbers, magical
support.
Even with their own skills, the
new allies.
The combined effects take their
toll.
Restraints, sedatives, guards,
magic.
It's too much.
It's a stark reminder heroes
aren't invincible.
Preparation circumstance.
They heavily influence the
outcome.
This is Barovia's brutal
reality.
Even a good plan can crumble
under pressure complications and
the consequences become dire.
Radley and Derman are felled in
rapid succession.
Oh no, both go down.
Yeah, and it begins to appear
the execution will occur as
scheduled.
A truly dire moment signals A
devastating defeat for the
rescue attempt.
All that sacrifice, all that
risk for nothing.
Hashtag, hashtag, tag, tag.
A desperate retreat and a
painful cost.
Just as all seems completely
lost, a desperate heroic act
shifts things again.
The were Ravens.
What do they do?
They take decisive action and
hoist both the fallen
adventurers to their shoulders.
Grabbing the unconscious one
while still fighting.
Yeah, despite being stabbed and
pierced repeatedly while doing
it, they retreat to the wagon
carrying the unconscious
adventures.
They refuse to let their new
allies fall.
Wow, that's incredibly heroic
self sacrificing.
They're severely wounded, but
they prioritize the unconscious
adventurers, risking their own
lives to save them.
Irwin, still in War Raven form,
urges.
The horse pulls the wagon
through the square.
Creating a chaotic, desperate
escape.
Spears and shouts following
them.
Your horn sees them fleeing,
rides his Panther down the
backside of the buildings to
follow the wagon provides cover,
ensures their escape they.
Quickly outpace the pursuing
guards, who throw their Spears
at the fleeing adventurers.
A narrow escape from immediate
danger.
Antic Desperate dash for
survival.
A harrowing flight, but it comes
at a terrible price.
A heart wrenching 1.
What is it?
What's the cost?
Here's the profound, gut
wrenching consequence, the twist
that underscores Borovia's
brutality.
Despite all the effort, the new
alliances, the immense risks,
the stupefied Tracidor is left
behind alone to face the Burger
mistress's wrath and justice.
Oh man, they had to leave him.
They couldn't get to him.
He was still in the gallows,
sedated.
They had to save the ones they
could reach.
That raises such a deeply
emotional question.
What happens when even your best
efforts fall short?
Right.
Despite the bravery, the
alliances, the risks, they
failed to save one of their own.
This is the emotional gut punch
of the session.
A devastating loss amidst A
partial victory.
What are the implications for
morale, the mission and
Traxidor's fate?
Unknown.
Terrifying.
It's a snark reminder.
In Barovia, even a partial win
can come with a devastating,
heartbreaking cost.
Forces the players and us to
confront that reality.
Not every outcome can be
controlled.
Sacrifice is often unavoidable.
Wow, so the cart carrying the
unconscious rabbly in Dermont,
it successfully escapes from the
square.
It gets away from the chaos.
Driven through the streets for
several minutes, a frantic dash
eventually leading them away
from immediate pursuit.
The chase is over for now.
Yeah, the immediate danger seems
to have passed, but the
psychological aftermath, that's
just beginning.
Right.
The priority after that kind of
escape?
Yeah, Find refuge anywhere,
however temporary.
They find this fleeting haven in
a rough cellar of an abandoned
residence.
Somewhere to hide from the
pursuit they know is coming.
Cocktra won't let this go.
No way.
It's not a permanent solution,
but it's a moment to breathe,
assess the damage, mourn their
loss.
That temporary sanctuary just
underscores the constant
vigilance needed in Barovia.
Safety's never guaranteed, only
bought with constant effort.
Irwin the male were Raven.
He immediately drives the wagon
off after dropping them,
disappears into the mists again.
Leaving Danica to tend to the
fallen.
Right.
And your Horn observes, maybe
with some surprise, that Danica
is barely injured, despite
having suffered several deep
wounds during that brutal fight.
That's remarkable resilience
her.
Explanation is pretty offhand,
she just says her kind heal
quickly.
A vital piece of info about war
Ravens explains their incredible
toughness during the fight, able
to take blows that would drop
others.
Positions them as truly
extraordinary allies capable of
recovering quickly.
Makes them even more valuable
and dangerous.
And confirms the depth of their
commitment, the secrets they
hold.
Her instructions to your horn
are clear, urgent.
He's to stay hidden and not draw
attention to themselves.
Because Walker will have surf
parties out.
Exactly.
Once the coast is clear, then
they should make their way back
to the inn.
It's a pragmatic plan born of
necessity, fear.
Makes it crystal clear they are
far from safe.
This is just a temporary
respite, a moment to catch their
breath, lick their wounds.
The Burgo Mistresses wrath will
be swift, relentless, making
their regrouping their next
moves absolutely crucial for
survival.
The hunt is on and the players
are now the haunted puts
tremendous pressure on your
horn, now responsible for the
others.
Danica then closes the sellers
bulkhead doors and further
conceals it stacking crates.
Wicker works other cast off
items atop the doors.
Hiding their temporary, even
smart, practical.
A small but significant act
securing their desperate hiding
place.
With her work done, she
transforms back into a Raven
form and flies off.
Leaving your horn alone with the
unconscious adventurers.
Wow.
This session ends on this
profound cliffhanger fraught
with tension, devastating
consequences. 2 adventurers
unconscious, 1 left behind to
face who knows what terrifying
fate.
Survivors in hiding.
Powerful enemy actively hunting
them, the Marta coughs.
Powerful allies now, but they've
put themselves in grave danger,
their secrets out.
What will happen to Traxidor
alone and watchers grasp?
How will your horn Radley Derman
regroup, recover physically,
Emotionally?
The stakes have never been
higher.
Every future decision colored by
this painful loss sets up an
incredible emotional narrative
challenge for the campaign.
Hashtag tag.
Tag outro.
So, given all that, what does
this all mean for understanding
Borovia?
The choice is made under
pressure.
We've just witnessed this deep
dive into a narrative packed
with desperate gambles, truly
unexpected revelations, and the
harsh realities of a cursed land
where heroism comes at a
devastating price.
That rescue attempt heroic?
Daring, Absolutely.
But the cost?
Heartbreaking.
One friend left behind a face
who knows what.
Two others, severe, searly,
injured and a powerful enemy in
a fully aware and raged,
actively hunting them.
Indeed, the session just
highlights some brutal truths
about Borovia, of the intense
choices made under extreme
pressure.
It's a story of unexpected
heroism from allies like the
Martikoffs.
Amazing reveal.
The sheer resilience, the
desperate courage of the
adventurers, and the enduring
pervasive threat of Strad's
domain, where even small
victories are bought with blood
sacrifice.
The future for your horn Derman
Radley fraught with uncertainty
and Tracidor's fate hangs heavy.
It's a powerful lesson in
building tension, consequences,
making every player decision
resonate.
This whole experience, it raises
this important question, right
Eckers?
Far beyond the mists of Barovia.
When you're facing those
overwhelming odds, making
frantic life or death decisions,
when a rescue turns into this
frantic fight for survival and
the cost is so painfully high,
what truly stands out to you as
the critical take away?
What would you sacrifice to save
a friend, or maybe to secure
your own skin?
When the enemy is relentless and
the darkness feels absolute.